blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman it was completely predictable
that republican senator ted cruz's
approval rating was going to fall
among democrats and among left-leaning
independents
after he in a completely i mean i i
don't know what he was thinking
but he well actually i do know what he
was thinking he fled with his family to
cancun
when the power went out in his home
state of texas and what he was thinking
was
quite clear which is i want to have
power let's go somewhere where it's warm
and there's power that's exactly what he
was thinking
um until it completely blew up in his
face and so we were expecting that his
already low approval among democrats and
left-leaning independents
was going to fall but ted cruz's
approval rating has collapsed
20 points among republican
voters and this is really a signal of
the worst situation for ted cruz
since he took office in 2013 quite
frankly according to a yahoo
yougov poll uh 24
of voters approve of him overall and 49
disapprove that's a net approval of
minus 25 for ted cruz but that's overall
and when you look at
the republican numbers in a morning
consult poll
ted cruz is at 53 approval among
republicans that's down 23 points
from january on january 9th
after the trump riots 76 percent of
republicans supported ted cruz
and that number is now down 23 points to
53 percent
republican support for ted cruz nearly
half of the republican party
does not approve of ted cruz and that is
absolutely
stunning uh ted cruz's approval was
already
sort of on the decline in january
if you go back to december you see that
in the period
uh from december 27 to january 5
cruz's approval was 81 among republicans
then january 6 to 9 the immediate
aftermath
of the riot he was down from 81 to 76
approval among republicans and then now
53
approval among republicans now for
us the unfortunate reality and it's been
a reality
that's much bigger than ted cruz for a
long time ted cruz isn't up for
re-election until 2024. he just won
in 2018 six-year terms for senators
up again in 2024 that's an insanely long
amount of time for this to have any
effect electorally
i know that we can hope that voters will
remember this in 2024
i think it's just too long uh the
circumstances
in 2024 for ted cruz are going to be
far more dictated by what's going on
at the time is trump the republican
nominee
or not uh other factors at that point
and if this were to have an effect it
would be getting ted cruz to resign
now there seems to be no chance that
that happens i've seen no indication
whatsoever no reason to think ted cruz
is going to resign over this
the way out of ted cruz as a senator in
texas
is to register new voters and to get out
the vote it's not to convert
existing republican voters what we've
learned many times
is that if you rely on republican voters
to remember the horrible things that
their elected officials did
you don't win it's just not a winning
strategy is what we've learned over time
ted cruz will have a bounce back he has
now
four years to start getting on all of
the tired tropes so we've got to fight
socialism and the debt is a little
you know all that stuff he'll have a
bounce back there will
be some you know tragedy of some kind
that will allow him to talk about how
the left wants to take your guns
and uh if he wants to be reelected he
almost certainly will
if we leave it to republicans
in texas to decide and remember the
things he did
the way to defeat ted cruz is to get out
the vote and to register new voters
and um if this re-election campaign for
cruz were maybe in 2022
there'd be more of a shot at the cancun
fiasco having an
impact if it were 2021 it would be even
better
but the cautious optimism for 2024
is that cruz did only defeat beto
o'rourke by
a small margin about 51-48 in 2018.
if the election were now or in a few
months and we were hammering hammering
hammering on get out the vote and
registering voters
i think beto o'rourke would have a real
shot at defeating ted cruz
four years from now makes it more
difficult to predict
but let's prove ourselves wrong if ted
cruz is going to be defeated on 2024 it
will be because of the campaign that we
mount
then we saw the model in georgia with
stacey abrams and registering new new
voters
joe biden winning georgia two democratic
challengers
uh in the senate in georgia defeating
two republican incumbents
in georgia so it can be done we've seen
the the playbook
simply waiting for the cancun fiasco to
affect
republicans four years from now that's
not the winning strategy i'm open to
having my mind changed but i've seen no
evidence that that's the way to
win that seat back this is just
completely predictable but also
disastrously humiliating we have now
learned
that a close ally per cnn of georgia
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
participated participated
in the january 6th riots in washington
dc
and was among those who ultimately made
their way
into the building we've been covering
marjorie taylor green
as one of quite a few trumpy
radical right-wing members of congress
that won solely because of
their support of donald trump and
marjorie taylor green in particular has
been promoting
all sorts of conspiracies and dangerous
ideas
she encouraged the idea untrue idea that
the election was somehow stolen by joe
biden from donald trump
she tweeted that those who broke into
the capital weren't even really
republicans they were
antifa dressed up as trump supporters
but unfortunately
a guy named anthony aguero a
conservative live
streamer activist and associate of
marjorie taylor greens
is on video saying he was among those
who entered
it wasn't done by antifa it was really
pro-trump republicans who did it
he said quote on video we were all there
it was not antifa
and it was not black lives matter it was
trump supporters that did that yesterday
i'm the first to
admit it being one myself i walked
amongst
all those people this is a close
associate of marjory taylor greens green
and aguero
worked closely together on immigration
related issues the border wall they went
to pro-trump rallies together
a bunch of videos have since been
deleted but
marjorie taylor greene has called aguero
amazing
and a friend and aguero called green one
of my closest
friends this is an associate of marjorie
taylor greens
who was an activist with marjorie taylor
green who was at the trump riots and
participated in the trump riots
now will there be any repercussions for
marjorie taylor green as a result of
this
i don't think so i don't think so at
this point we have seen
that you can essentially get away with
anything in the republican party without
having to resign without having
repercussions it was even shocking to me
that marjorie taylor green was stripped
of her committee assignments because of
uh the things that that she said in the
aftermath of the january sixth
uh uh riots but uh the the only way out
of this is she has to be soundly
defeated in 2022. now i'm
already seeing all sorts of very
confident uh statements that marjorie
taylor greene
is facing a bloodbath for re-election in
2022
she's going to be soundly defeated it's
going to be humiliating she's going to
be made a one-term congresswoman
let's seize up on that a little bit it's
not totally clear to me that that's
guaranteed to be the way that it goes
there's a bunch of different things that
can happen one is we don't know what the
political tide will be at the national
level in 2022
it could be that this sunday donald
trump at his cpac speech
announces he's running in 2024 and it
could be that
something happens between now and 2022
and donald trump personally campaigns
for marjorie taylor green and she gets
herself re-elected i think anybody
assuming she doesn't
is not thinking uh empirically at this
point in time
the other thing we have to remember for
those of us hoping for a humiliating
defeat for marjorie taylor green
in november of 2022 is that if it's
obvious that she has no shot she may
just
say she's not running for reelection to
save face she may
say you know what i did my one term
unfortunately because of the fake news
and the socialist democrats and all of
this canceled culture
they are limiting my ability to do
anything so i'm going to be able to
better work for the people by going back
to georgia and doing
who the hell knows what some lobbying
gig for all i know i don't know
but that is also a sort of escape
pod that if if it's abundantly clear
she's going to lose she also just may
not run for re-election so
we just want her gone i don't care if
she loses in 2022 or chooses not to run
but if you're just assuming she's going
to get soundly defeated
i think you're getting a little bit a
little bit ahead of yourself there
okay we have a fantastic program today i
do want to remind you i will be
live streaming cpac on sunday the final
speeches at the
conservative political action conference
which will include a speech by former
president donald trump possibly to
announce his 2024 candidacy i hope you
will join me sunday
for the rare weekend live stream on
youtube twitch and facebook
but we still have a fantastic program
for you today and we'll continue
right after this send me your thoughts
about the marjorie taylor green
situation you can find me on twitter
at the pacman the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show of
course is funded primarily by
memberships memberships you can get
quickly easily
beautifully perfectly at joinpacman.com
the coupon code still works that code is
better21
which will save you i mean it just saves
you so much i'm not even comfortable
telling you how much
let's listen into or not let's listen in
let's talk to
some folks in the audience who have
questions
comments about the last week of the
political world
we are taking calls via the david pakman
show discord
server which you can join at
davidpakman.com
slash discord the waiting lobby
is the place to participate let's go
next to patrick from
vernon hills patrick from vernon hills
you're on the air
hey david uh can you hear me yes i can
cool
i have maybe more of a historical
question for you but
do you have any examples of
maybe the us or other countries that
have gone from times of
heavy propaganda or sensational news
to better news systems and
how have nations done that like what
regulations or laws or social movements
um in particular i'm thinking of like
the yellow journalism
in the 20th century or the red scare
in the middle of the 21st yeah i mean i
guess
my mind goes to transitioning from from
uh two thoughts come to mind
world war ii and cold war
where there was a lot of propaganda i
mean i think like
okay take estonia as an example which i
think is an interesting one because
they're one of the countries that has
best sort of
recovered from the fall of the soviet
union and exited the cold war
very technologically advanced uh very
open when it comes to prep media i i
think that the examples
always go along with some change in the
type of government you have
and so i think that that maybe is a
cautionary tale
from the standpoint of to really get
away
from a media apparatus
and maybe government propaganda
apparatus that that is weaponized
this information you typically need
substantive change
to uh who's in charge and the type of
people that are in charge but but i
think estonia is sort of an interesting
example in the post-soviet union era
cool thanks uh one more if you're fine
with it
uh yeah angie yang has proposed a few
times
giving people money to invest in uh
their local journalism outlets so on
your tax returns you get like 100 bucks
or something
and you can only uh use that to donate
to
a person or organization that's
registered as a news organization to
help
rebuild local news outlets uh what do
you think of that proposal
that's very interesting i i've not heard
of that i've heard of another idea
where you can designate money for um
local elected officials rather than i
think when you do your taxes is the
question of like do you want to put
three bucks towards like the
presidential
election fund or something like that
i've never met anybody who says yes to
that but some people must
um the idea of doing it for for local i
i think it's very interesting i think
the devil is in the details i'd want to
know
more about exactly how it's done but i
like the idea
cool thank you all right and by the way
i think i like the idea better
of with the politicians one of just
getting money out of politics and having
public financing of elections rather
than
giving people the option to participate
in the system let's change the system
but when it comes to when it comes to
media i think it's more interesting
yeah the freedom dividend i thought was
a genius idea i never heard that until
in g yang and it just
really changed i was so pessimistic
about money and politics
until i heard that i was like it's
genius like
all right my friend thank you for the
call thank you all right take care
uh okay very good let's go
where are we going next let's go to
uh let's go to katherine gg
i don't know what if that's a location
what is gg katherine is that a
where you are hello
dave yes hello hi yes
i'm from arkansas but i go to college in
tulsa oklahoma
oh okay very good um so i've got a
question about
trump's upcoming uh cpac speech
yes so i i know there's gonna be
like some news that kind of he might
uh announce his 2024 candidacy like
i honestly don't care about that i don't
care what he has to say about like 2022
either because you know with the ongoing
legal investigation
something might happen before right but
what i'm most
what what i'm worried about is like if
he's gonna say anything about the
supreme court ruling on his tax returns
um i know he's already re i know he's
already had a statement in response to
that
but um well what are you
what are you worried about like what
would he say that worries you
like i like i don't know like he could
probably like be spreading some
while like like i know this is
hypothetical
it's over exaggerated but you know like
how predictable is he
honestly you know like he's always got
targets such as the media and the
democrats and like
you know like the the court system like
he like he thinks everything is rigged
against him
like do you think he could like start
spreading conspiracies about
how unfair the court system could be oh
it wouldn't be that he starts i mean
anytime a court has ruled against him he
either you know i mean it goes back to
attacking that judge
um in 2017 and saying the judge couldn't
couldn't fairly rule because his parents
are mexican
so tr of course trump will do that i
just don't think that it's a particular
concern i mean he's an ex-president yes
he's going to speak at cpac on sunday
i think the most impactful thing he
could do would be to announce his 2024
candidacy
he'll probably rail against who knows
who for treating him unfairly i think at
this point we all expect it i don't
think it'll have much of an impact
okay well i i'm just curious because you
know like
if these legal investigations like if
something does really come up like he is
convicted
and possibly sent to um
prison for whatever charges are entailed
it's not gonna happen
uh well like hi well what about like his
followers in the case that something
like that happened
like what would they do trump trump's
just not going to prison i mean i don't
know that it
even is worth hypothesizing okay
all right sorry if that's like an
over-exaggerated or
hypothetical thing but no no i mean it's
good it's good to think about these
things just the u.s doesn't jail
past presidents and i just don't uh you
know people have asked that off and on
for the last year i don't think it's
going to happen
okay all right well thanks for reaching
out david yeah thanks catherine very
much appreciate the call catherine
from arkansas in tulsa very very
exciting
let's go next to bobby from new jersey
bobby from jersey you're on
hello david how are you how's it going
it's going it's going well bobby thank
you
thank you um my thing my question is
is that a lot of times a lot of lefty
commentators often cite that
things like medicare for all has a 70
approval rating
but a lot of times they'll consider that
it's soft support and don't
and don't know that that does that the
support
is um goes down whenever it's mentioned
that there's a tax increase
and yeah so let's bobby i don't want to
interrupt you but i want to make clear
i do to i cover that every time i talk
about support for medicare for all so it
sounds like you're talking about other
commentators which i wouldn't really be
able to speak to but i completely agree
with you
there's very detailed information about
this the kaiser family foundation
has shown that you know the more details
you give about how medicare all would
actually work i don't mean
scaremongering about government
takeovers and communism just accurate
information
support does go down so i think it's
fair to say some medicare for all
support
is softer right but i was all but the
point
is is that a lot of people kind of take
polls
um too literally and oftentimes don't
i say don't know the fine details behind
them
right i agree with you i agree with you
and that's the case with many more
issues than just medicare for all now i
think
it's also important bobby to know that
regardless of whether something is or
isn't popular or
is or is not understood by the public it
might be a good thing or a bad thing
like that's also
that's a different discussion
yes and do you think sometimes the qua
the quad the quantity is the support
isn't as important as the quality of the
support like well i mean trump has never
heard
the majority sure had strong support the
problem in general with basing whether
something should happen
solely on whether it has support is that
the us as a population has supported
really bad things
many times in history and there are
arguably certain things we shouldn't put
to a popular vote i mean you look at
you know when states vote about should
two gay people be able to get married
why are we even putting that to a vote
like it's a fundamental just basic human
rights issue so
i think that looking at popular support
for issues and candidates is one piece
of how we analyze the merits of
something but it's just one piece
right thank you david all right my
pleasure bobby from jersey
always great to hear from you why don't
we go next
to let's go to lj from vegas
lj from las vegas what's going on hey
david i'm actually a long time listener
uh glad thank you for taking my call how
are how are things in vegas you know
normally i go twice a year but i've not
been now because of the pandemic since
october
of 2019 i'm hopeful that i will be
back in october of this year if all goes
well
how has it been um you know funny thing
you say that um
a lot of my family right now at the
moment they're currently on unemployment
thankfully here we do have a governor
that's been taking good care of us
yeah i'm not on unemployment i went back
after a few months
um to my job uh the funny thing is i
actually got to meet sam cedar
at one of the conventions you come out
to vegas for oh really you were supposed
to arrive but he said something uh maybe
you were
in a doctor's appointment or you had
some kind of uh
i'm not going to get into the specifics
but
now i had hold on i had a doctor's
appointment in vegas
no no no no no um you were um where you
are right um
um when i had the appendectomy that's
right i when i had my emergency well as
i mean every every appendectomy is is
mostly an emergency unless you're going
somewhere where you needed
to have preemptively removed which
sometimes happens
when you go on certain missions to
antarctica they require pre-emptive
appendix removal but
no that's right i ended up not making it
because
it was only a few weeks after my
appendectomy and i was not
i was not cleared to uh lift my luggage
so i couldn't go that's absolutely right
yeah i was hoping to meet you too
because i actually worked for the the
convention you were going to so i worked
for the exhibitor services department so
i was super excited to meet you but then
uh sam cedar was like no he's not coming
out and i was like oh man i would have
loved to
like shook your hand and said hello next
time we should we'll hopefully be back
in october
oh i don't work for that uh property
anymore oh okay as much as i wish but if
you're ever in vegas you ever need
someone to show you around be more than
glad to
give you a you know a lift or help you
in any way so i love it
um just uh one comment i wanted to make
though um
and um one thing that i've always wanted
to discuss is that
i always feel that here in the united
states or at least globally how we look
like
is we're always defined on the smaller
percentage of and at whatever percentage
that might be
of the extremes of let's say the right
and the left
right and i i always feel like
it is a unvalued argument to always
constantly
keep saying well in america you have
this problem and
um of you know all these issues and
everything like that and it's just a
suppression of the minority that always
gets the
um the spotlight rather than i'm gonna
push back
no i don't know that i agree let me push
back a little bit on that so i think
that there's a difference so so
i guess like let's imagine would you
agree just for our conversation that we
kind of established that
the the wacky far right that is
sometimes discussed would be kind of
like
q anon white supremacists uh these
people who think bill gates is going to
microchip you
and that you know there's no virus like
would are we okay with that as the car
the cartoon of the far right oh yeah
absolutely okay
and then are we okay with like the
cartoon of the far left as like
actual communist socialist marxists who
want
stalinist ussr whatever like could we
say that's the left caricature
i i as a as a cuban american completely
push back on that of course that you
know that's who i am but yes i do agree
that that's the characteristic of the
far left
if you go elsewhere in the world the us
isn't known for this socialist left
contingent
if you look at other parts of the world
when people
think about what what is the us they see
the u.s
way more as a sort of libertarian
free market capitalism unhinged thing
and so while you and i
might say that what i just outlined is
typically
seen as the the extreme left by which
the us is judged
the world doesn't look at the us and
think that the so-called socialists or
communists or whatever
really have much of an impact and the
truth is that they don't i mean none of
them are in power
i think so so i don't know that i agree
with you that around the world that's
how the us is
sort of caricatured no i know i
completely agree with you
what i'm trying to say is that sometimes
people think that the america
itself is like uh what what's what's a
what's a good representation of this is
that we're all gun-toting maniacs who
just want to shoot each other constantly
right now you're talking that often is
the perception in much of the rest of
the world you're right now
where yeah well and you know i i
completely agree that there are
a percentage of people in the united
states who are people who love to have
guns and love to you know what's it
called use them
sure in any aspect of their life i do
feel like the
the overwhelming um people who are in
the united states of the uh you know
do have a mixed opinion and i know
you've discussed
with other like special guests of yours
right where it's not a left-right issue
it's more of like a quadrant
yeah yes you may be liberal on some
things but you might also be
uh what what is it um well it's a
authoritarian libertarian and then
economically left right
is often the kind of four box quadrant
that's used
correct and i i think that if we fall
into the trap of constantly trying to
make everything left and right
yeah then we're missing the issues you
know the grander issue of
not everybody falls into a left-right
kind of personality agree
certainly no no argument there yeah and
that's just
that's just the comment i wanted to make
that sometimes maybe we should stop
going from what's
what's left doing what's the right doing
but what are people doing specifically
in in their you know aspects and lives
no argument from me my friend
thank you all right lj from las vegas
thank you so much for the call we're
gonna take a quick break if you're
holding and wanting to talk to me don't
hang up
because we're going to take some more
calls right after this short break
the david pakman show at
[Music]
the davidpakman.com one funding source
for the david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world-famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay let's go back to the phones by
which i mean
discord davidpakman.com discord
i want to hear next from tamesha
to misha you're on the air what's going
on hi david
how are you i'm from i'm a teacher in
new york city public schools
okay and um i'm a co-teacher so i work
with another teacher and
she we're also good friends so she told
me
that she voted for trump and well
fundamentally i don't believe that you
should decide a friendship
based on that but at the same time i had
feelings like i felt a way about the
fact that she voted for trump she gave
me her reasons we talk about it a lot
but i've i really still felt ryan we got
into an argument about it
we made up and everything but so what do
you think about
maintaining a friendship well is it is
uh so
you you learned she voted for trump and
that disturbed you and then you talked
about why
how do you feel about the reasons why
she voted for trump
her reasons um were based on
misinformation but i
understood where she was coming from
like she said that she was afraid of
socialism she lives in jersey and she
doesn't like
the her government governor which is
democratic and stuff like that and she
was a democrat she switched
to independent and you know some her
reason like the socialist part i was
like you don't really understand that
it's not like our country's going to
become socialist
right i mean does she think joe biden is
a socialist
well she really thinks joe biden's just
not has dementia is not
she you know it's a lot of that fake
news stuff that she she listens to yeah
that's tough i mean listen you're in a
position where this is not only a friend
but it's someone you're working with so
i you know i think it's
it's a very personal decision the the
one thought i have is
if you don't feel as though you've
learned things about this person
where you believe that you now are
sort of in some way uh
targeted by them or that they have
beliefs which are directly hostile to
you like okay
it sounds like you're saying she fell
for the idea that
that if trump loses there's gonna be
socialism that was wrong
but it doesn't necessarily mean that she
now has to have a hostile relationship
with you like if you feel as though
you disagree with this person and
they're misinformed about things and
have come
to the wrong conclusions but it's not
hostile to you in a direct way
then i would understand especially
because you have to work with them that
you maintain the relationship but it's a
very personal decision to make
yeah i agree i mean she like we talk
about politics a lot because we're both
very interested
and she she does value my opinion i
value her opinion and
um we talked it out and she i told i
explained that to her about the whole
socialism fear
and she was like oh okay that makes me
feel better because i
i really don't want our country to turn
into that and
i'm curious at some point did you say
do you know what socialism is let me
understand what when you say
socialism what do you mean and see if
she even knows what it is
was that something you tried um yeah she
feels like it's like um
big government and free everything and
and she doesn't like the idea of
universal healthcare which i
do yeah um for all yeah so she's pretty
misinformed about what these things even
are it sounds like
yeah basically but like i said i don't i
still value her friendship and we're
still friends
and i don't let it get to me but i did
feel a little off-putting about the fact
that she did wind up voting for trump
i agree but listen it sounds like all in
all
this is this is very tolerable and
overall it sounds like it's more
positive than negative for you
yes yeah well there there's your answer
thanks
all right thanks tamisha uh keep up the
great work teaching in new york that's a
big deal
let's go next where do we want to go
next how about
uh oh i don't know there's a lot of
interesting callers here
let's go to um why don't we go to
john from philly john from philly you're
on the air
hey uh daily how are you sir
good how are you very good very good
hey um i just discovered this
link to call you because i tried to call
you from the previous
way to call you from the 617 but it's
no longer work it's done that's right
it's all discord now
okay perfect i was just wondering what
did you
uh believe uh the uh
republican party is is
going to like uh i don't know i feel
like
the republican party is down like
hold on john did you say done or dumb
completely oh completely done okay yeah
i don't believe that they can win
another election i mean in the white
house i mean
i could be wrong i don't know well
listen
so i i have two thoughts and john we've
spoken before right you're from the
dominican republic if i recall correctly
yeah
okay yeah yeah i remember you so here's
the thought on the one hand
when you look at what's going on and you
see
how donald trump led to republicans
losing the house in 2018
losing the white house and the senate in
2020 and
um distrust in so many different aspects
of what the republican party
stands for it's hard to imagine how
could they win
without changing what they're doing but
we've said this many times before john
where we say wow
the republic now they definitely can
never win again
and then they win again so i would be
careful about saying there's no way they
can win
the things i'm going to be looking out
for are what happens in 2022 do
republicans in 2022
reject the trumpian candidates like
marjorie taylor greene and others
or do they get re-elected if they get
re-elected in 2022
there will be a fight for who represents
the republican party in 2024.
if in 2022 all of these trump people get
voted out and the republican party goes
back to being what it was
i think they'll probably be mostly back
together by the time of the next
presidential election that's my thought
right now
so don't uh did you think they are not
gonna go back to the values
of being uh like before like when
the reagan uh kind of thing like yeah
when he was in power like the uh
uh what's i call it the uh like the
focus
the focus on welfare reform trickle-down
economics the debt
religion that type of thing you mean
yeah like the the prince
principle of uh being a
conservative right you know yeah that
was the
way of policy
but now everything changed and now is
they are completely in another life far
far right now it's like absolutely
absolutely
the way i would say it is they've become
about
just angering the left that's that's
their philosophy now what can we do that
will anger the left
trump was never about policy the few
policies he ran on
like replacing obamacare building a wall
fixing trade he didn't do any of those
things and for the last two years of
trump
they didn't even pretend to care about
policy so you're asking a great question
which is do they go back to what they
pretended to be during the 80s and 90s
i think it's too soon to know i think we
just have to wait and see john
yeah well i don't know to me the
republican party is not going to be this
thing anymore
i think it'll never it won't even if it
goes back to being about what it was
it will never be the same because they
can't erase the fact that they had trump
for four years and i think that's
that will cause some irreversible change
for sure
yeah yeah i completely agree
thank you appreciate it hope the hope
things are well in philly there's john
from philly
always great to talk to him why don't we
go next
to um
let's go to ricky allen from iowa ricky
allen from iowa
you're on the air
ricky you from iowa you've got to unmute
and then we'll be able to hear you and
talk
hey david what's the party there you are
how are you
no i'm actually ricky from j-a-j-a which
is jamaica
oh from jamaica okay uh i guess it must
be some kind of lowercase
j that looks like an i no it's g
capital g yes um this is my second time
coming in i was actually a first
jamaican caller
you were i remember that okay cool
so what i wanted to ask though is um
absolutely um i'm starting to get
extremely concerned with the
um political dynamic on the left yes um
in which because at one point um
i do not want to call any name but there
are certain people
there are certain um individual or
commentators on the left which i think
are becoming
very counterproductive towards
um a political ends in which i think
their view politics in such a what is
idealistic framework
and not so much of a pragmatic framework
and
that in my opinion in which how do you
think
we um can be more pragmatic and ensure
that
our ideology our form of leftistism
um come to fear refutation and because
um those commentators he will lead you
more
into a right-wing direction and not so
much of
us obtaining the political goal that's
very interesting this is a critique i've
had of of some of the left now
i'm curious ricky are you talking about
politicians or media people that you
believe are falling too far towards
idealism rather than pragmatism
oh media media people oh really because
honestly at one point my introduction to
leftism was
basically kyle kulinsky
and honestly right now i do not listen
to claire currency
i think is his approach to politics
is extremely silly and counterproductive
because you think he's you you're saying
he's too idealistic and not pragmatic
enough
that's exactly what i'm saying and x and
jimmy dork jimmy dore
also these these um their way of viewing
politics
i think lead people to a bit more
um when they try to equivocate the left
are the democratic party in the
republican party like there is seem
uh when you have jimmy dore saying that
the reason why people does not have
health care
is because of aoc like do stuff
makes us make the left in my opinion
my opinion right um not as productive as
we want it to be
see that's interesting i i think that
you know i don't know
the jimmy dore stuff i think jimmy's
operating in a different
sort of universe i'm more familiar with
kyle's views
there's a difference between useful
idealism
to kind of set the goal in a reasonable
way
versus counterproductive cynicism so in
my
this is a very limited experience
because i've i really don't watch
other shows like mine i've seen a few
jimmy door clips over the last two three
months
when we talked about his um his attacks
on me or whatever
jimmy dore right now i would
characterize as
counterproductively cynical and
full stop with kyle i'd need to see the
examples you're talking about but in my
experience one of the differences
between kyle and me
is that he certainly is more idealistic
and i'm more pragmatic
but i think there's a real value to
idealism because if you have only
pragmatists
you get into a vortex of
only focusing on incrementalism and i
think that
having the idealism as part of it
as long as it doesn't get you beyond
being willing to accept
steps in the right direction i think
idealism is valuable
yeah i do i do agree with idealism right
yeah
it's valuable but you have to be
idealistic and pragmatic at the same
time
i completely agree and what i'm hearing
you say you're saying
you're saying kyle yeah you're saying
kyle is idealistic but not pragmatic
enough
yes because i am sure that you're
probably an idealistic person too but
however you will see that
in order for you to get a certain end
are obtained as
a political and you have to um
be a bit more pragmatic there because as
i said there's nothing wrong with being
idealistic
yeah it's how do we get that idealism
we have to be pragmatic so all right
well i think uh ricky i think your
critique is
well understood and you've made it
respectfully and i appreciate it
okay thank you very much all right ricky
from jamaica by the way how are
things okay in jamaica right now yeah
man
we're very we're doing pretty good here
good all right
all right ricky from jamaica hope to
hear from you again
um let's go to a quick break sorry i
wasn't able to hear from everybody
but we will take calls again and i hope
to hear from you next time
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week david now with more
hindsight can we finally
say what george w bush's legacy is
and how does it compare to what you
thought it would be when he left office
this is a really interesting question i
actually see
george w bush's legacy now
many years out from his presidency as
exactly what i believed it would be when
george w bush
left office now you could make the case
it just hasn't been enough time we need
to wait
even more time to know what george w
bush's real
long-term legacy is going to be but
uh sort of around the edges from the
point of view of
uh of tone rather than substance george
w
bush was known for being sort of the
dumb president not particularly bright
i think the trump presidency has put
that
in context like at least george w bush
read books uh you know the he he was
dumb-ish but not as dumb as donald trump
on policy and failures
uh george w bush's legacy when he left
office was that of
a war criminal who went to war with the
wrong country
after the 9 11 attacks invading iraq
and starting the disaster that we now uh
know of and even have much agreement on
from many republicans
as to that war uh also
in the post-9 11 era george w bush's
legacy
is the patriot act um and
the sort of start of a
progressive set not progressive
politically but a growing and advancing
uh set of restrictions on privacy of
many kinds including via technological
means the failure on katrina
certainly hurricane katrina one of the
main
legacy elements of george w bush
and that's really what we believed when
george w
bush left office and uh this is
interesting from the standpoint of being
able to tell versus not being able to
tell legacy relatively quickly
i mean i think the the question would be
if you went back to
fdr did we know fdr's legacy
right when when he was no longer in
office i i think looking at the
contemporaneous writing you sort of did
um getting the us and the world beyond
world war
ii and the um new deal
uh that that was widely written about at
the time and
i would argue is still the bulk of fdr's
legacy abraham lincoln you go back to
abraham lincoln and
quote freeing the slaves being part of
the union
around civil war times i don't know if
the term legacy was being used at the
time of lincoln's assassination
um but certainly it was clear that that
was
a big deal not everybody liked it but
that that was a big deal so
i i do think that the benefit of
hindsight is useful in thinking about
what is the legacy of a president and
the more distance you get from it the
the more important and useful that that
can be
but with george w bush at least the
his legacy was pretty clear right away
um
and now as we are um
13 years out from george w bush
it has remained that way now if there
are things i'm missing that you think
are part of george w bush's legacy let
me know
and then the question becomes what is
donald trump's legacy going to be
and uh not good i think is how i would
characterize it but we'll leave
the deeper analysis for another moment
david do you think that
trump policies are actually more popular
than republican policies this is an
interesting question because a lot of
trump policies aren't really policies
and and this is one of
the important things to understand that
gets us back to our discussion about
the allure the sometimes deceptive
allure
of a populist rhetoric which then
implodes
in either authoritarianism or
incompetence or in the case of donald
trump
both there are lots of quote
republican policies that are not very
popular anymore
if you look at just to pick something if
you look at the topic of abortion
the republican party uh continues to be
among its elected officials very
anti-choice
but the u.s population
has moved more and more to the left in
terms of
believing that abortion should be legal
and safe
in most cases so in that sense that's a
republican policy
that's not very popular with the
american people
the tricky and and sort of pernicious
thing about donald trump's quote
policies
is that many of them aren't actually
policies they're just vague
promises that are meant to play
on the resentment and discontent of
large swaths of americans so i'll give
you an example
when donald trump ran on we're getting
screwed on trade
you're getting screwed and you're
getting screwed whether you're a
democrat or a republican even if he
wasn't saying that everybody's getting
screwed and
china this and china that i understand
it and i'm going to fix it
that's not a policy but it
accurately sort of rang a bell
of discontent and resentment that many
people had
and in that sense it was a popular thing
for him to say
we can't really call it a popular policy
because it's not actually a policy and
as we saw when donald trump
um actually uh negotiated that trade
deal and said we fixed everything we
fixed nafta it was really nafta redux
with a different name
and a lot of the same elements the
policy itself was not actually any
better
than what we had before so i want to be
really careful about saying
trump's policies are more popular than
republican policies because many of them
aren't actually policies
another example um healthcare
donald trump got some favorable ratings
while he was
uh running for president on the idea of
getting rid of obamacare and replacing
it with something that's going to be
great and we're going to keep coverage
for pre-existing conditions
there were people who certainly liked
that and they arguably liked it
as well or better than the republican
proposals
um but there was really nothing there
and once the actual
proposal was put forward and it was
scored
and it was determined that 20 30 million
people would end up without care who
currently had it
didn't go anywhere and to even call it a
policy is a bit of a stretch and then
you have things that are
sort of more pedestrian i mean um a lot
of the things trump wanted were not
popular
trump was widely against you know no
covet mask mandate or really a
request from the presidency joe biden
did that it has 80
support so that clearly wasn't a popular
thing that donald trump
stood for building the wall was never
particularly popular you know it was
kind of right in their split among party
lines like
you start with party lines and shift a
little bit towards less popular
so i think for some of these things that
were more actual policy ideas from trump
they weren't particularly popular the
the reason the trump
policy platform if you can even call it
that
lulled a lot of people into supporting
it is that
it was essentially just populist
rhetoric which a lot of people like even
some people on the left
without actual policy prescriptions
which with
which when trump did actually put out uh
in detail
were widely unpopular right now
this continues to be a problem the
american electorate
is far to the left of where our
candidates are
the american electorate is well to the
left of the average of
the hundred senators on so many
different issues ranging from income
inequality what tax rates should be
all the way to social issues like
abortion so
a lot of republican and trump policies
aren't popular
but they continue to win in many ways
because
the wedge issues that are really great
fundraising
issues continue to be sort of wielded
like a cudgel by many republican elected
officials and candidates
and we'll have time to see if and how
that shifts between now
and the 2022 elections david why do you
think
christian prophets are on the rise again
this is a really interesting question
and there's a super
compelling article in the new york times
about christian prophets
and their predictions and one of the
points that the article makes
is that right now there is a real
hunger for reassurance and clarity
uh in many areas of american
culture in particular we have seen
donald trump be the least popular
president by approval rating in the
polling era
leave the white house with the lowest
approval rating
of any president in the polling era with
so many
failed promises from donald trump and
for the left who never believed any of
that stuff to begin with
and on average is less religious than
the right
and to the extent that the left is
religious it tends to be less the sort
of charismatic evangelical christianity
that is so much more prominent on the
right in the united states
the left isn't really looking for
prophecy
for reassurance and clarity because much
of the left never believed trump to
begin with
and much of the left doesn't look to
these sort of
um televangelist equivalents
for guidance on the right you saw
an initially resistant evangelical
christian wing of uh america resist
trump at the beginning sort of get
behind ted cruz and some other
candidates in the 2016 republican
primary
eventually trump won and they certainly
weren't going to vote for hillary
clinton so you saw a lot of these folks
who would not normally go
for the multiple times divorced guy who
pays off
uh uh porn stars and whatever else okay
they went with him and then everything
he promised he didn't do
now some of them just continued to
insist he did all of it
he was the most pro-life president and
all this different stuff
but many of them now are seeking some
kind of reassurance and clarity after
seeing trump not do any of the stuff he
promised to do
and then lose to joe biden who despite
actually being more devoutly religious
than donald trump
is catholic and is a democrat which does
not go too well
for a lot of these charismatic and
evangelical uh christian communities so
there's a big demand for someone who
will tell you
in clear terms here's what's going to
happen and that is part of the reason
why christian prophets are are sort of
seeing this
resuscitation newly popular once again
widely making wrong predictions as has
always been the case now interestingly
astrology is also expanding in
popularity
and the number of americans who believe
in psychics
are also expanding and i think that this
is just a general
sort of reaction to uncertain
political times combined with a global
hundred year pandemic
and the desire to have someone who will
tell you here's how things are going to
be
in your life in the political future of
the united states
etc we know that at minimum
one-third of americans say that they're
suffering from stress and anxiety
as a result of the pandemic when we ask
when will it be over we don't really
know we're starting to get more clarity
at least on the trajectory
over the next few months and things are
looking better and hopefully it'll keep
going that way
but for a year now we've had such
uncertainty that it is natural that
people would want answers and they would
want someone who will tell you
definitively
who is more arrogant in their
predictions
than these particular televangelist
type christian prophets whose income and
livelihood depends on
even if they don't know what the hell is
going to happen telling you that they
definitely do
and because of that i'm not particularly
surprised that this world of
christian punditry and prophecy
has surged in popularity if i'm missing
something in that analysis
let me know i'm curious to hear from you
we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today make sure you
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman